i can ask you about god religion and its
role in newton's life
was there
helpful
constructive
or destructive influences of religion
in his work and
in his life
well there you begin to touch on a
complex question um
the role that god played would be a
interesting question to answer should
one go and be able to speak with this
invisible character who doesn't exist
but putting that aside for the moment
yeah we don't like to talk about others
while they're not here so right
um newton is a deeply religious man not
unusually so of course for the
assignment
and um
clearly his upbringing
and perhaps his early experiences
have
exacerbated that in a number of ways
that he takes a lot of things personally
and and he finds perhaps solace
in thinking about a sort of governing
abstract
rule-making
exacting
deity
i think there is little question
that his
conviction
that you can figure things out
has a fair bit to do
with his profound belief
that this rule maker doesn't do things
arbitrarily
newton does not think that miracles have
happened
since maybe the time of christ
if then
and not in the same way he was for
instance an anti-trinitarian
he did not hold that christ had a divine
being
but was rather endowed with certain
powers by the rule maker and whatnot
and um
he
did not think that some of the uh
tales of the old testament with various
miracles and so on occurred in anything
like that way some may have some may not
have
like everybody else of course he did
think that creation had happened about 6
000 years ago
wait really oh yeah sure
well biblical chronology can give you a
little bit about that's a little
controversial but sure
interesting
wow the deity created
the universe
6 000 years ago and that didn't
interfere with his
uh playing around with the sun and the
moon and the oh no because he's figuring
out he's he's watching the brilliant
construction
that this
perfect entity did 6 000 years ago
yeah has produced plus or minus a few
years well if you go with bishop buster
it's 4004 bce
want to be precise about it
we always on this this is a serious
program we always want to be precise
you